how's it gone man how you doing man
today good yeah I just went upstairs I
came back on the lakeside to [ __ ] I ran
upstairs stuff in radio it is you got to
do in the break and there was no
drinking a lot of decaf if you have is
killing me that should have been good
for just caffeine is good coffee with
caffeine is cool because you drink in
your body understands what to do with it
but I think with decaf your body's like
why just risalah yeah Brown worthless
liquid is just sitting here well didn't
they have like those sugarfree gummy
bears that just instantly gave everyone
diarrhea or something like they look
like whatever a chemical they use like
cause people have a horrible already
told me that our commercial breaks have
gotten much more sudden yeah I got a
break we are right now Chavez not only
with you Minister station ID yeah I
don't know that the gummy bears though
it's not surprising time you think
there's something like take weight off
you or something there's some downside
to it right yeah it's like gives you
vegan gum Oh [ __ ] horrible gum wasn't
vegan or it I don't know I would have
[ __ ] point what's non vegan the part
that makes it chewy or the flavor
there's somebody's usual mister encou
are they use like hooves or something to
make them oh god I thought that's jell-o
oh yeah I can't imagine it get away with
it anymore
that's jello yeah these supposed to make
Jong yes yeah that's a they like
ground-up like either cow hooves or
horses oh yeah to make the whatever it
is like this the coagulating agent or
something yeah the gelatin is yet
gelatin is all I did a movie in Poland
and they really like gelatin clear
gelatin with meat stuck in it and then I
was like wow rough kind of a meal yeah
why it was a nice meal I got the hotel
like for dinner it's like this is what
we're having a hot man today it's
gelatin like I said just add texture
there flavor you know there wasn't any
flavors well just to spend the meat like
it is to show everybody
we're poland and it's a future yeah
favorite invasion of the body snatchers
would look like if it was little bits of
meat
creepy is it meat hot no it can't be
right it was yeah you have to you have
to put the jello in
frig yeah yeah oh yeah that would be
right yeah we'd like I can't imagine
that he's that up how it's disgusting
though it looks you never was called no
this was like in 2000 so it was not that
long after communism had fallen so there
was a sense of like real joy and certain
things like like there's lots of ice
cream stands everywhere there'd be an
ice cream break everyday like stuff that
people got to like you know enjoy for
the first time they hadn't under under
communism but oh you said all those just
kind of started yeah there's like nine
or ten years after you know and we were
really in like the countryside near
Krakow and like it was you know you'd
see some satellite dishes but also
people you know with a horse and
carriage doing their farm work that
seemed like it had been unchanged for a
really long time but it was just like
they were celebrating like look we've
got so much food we can just suspended
in gelatin right yeah we can really play
with this now yeah I've never been over
there it kind of scares me to God Poland
I want to go to yeah Russia I want to go
to craw I think Krakow is where the is
that we're all Schwartz's know well it's
kind of close there it's a couple hours
away in the countryside it's in it's so
disconcerting because all those places
all the horrible you know death camps
everything there in beautiful rolling
countryside in like wow this is just
sitting right here at me oh go to it
yeah you know it's fun I went to
Amsterdam and I kind of wanted to go to
the Anne Frank House but was just sold
out like impossible to get in there yeah
I went a couple or got almost ten years
ago now that our summer program for NYU
is in Amsterdam and I went there and
like it took like a couple weeks to find
in the morning when you can actually get
in line and go there I think it's even
more difficult than a shout out to the
believers when you finally go wow I
can't believe no one over his shoulder
was like don't know right now what he's
you already know where do you tell me
first what you're going to put in the
book of the sleep he said something to
the effect of like like I don't I
couldn't even don't stop believing
because it's journey well somewhat
Philippe eyes you would have been like
putting it on her like I hoped she would
have the sense to listen to my music it
was like yeah it was definitely some
kind of a shout-out to believing in the
believers like Anne Frank would have
been a beginner yeah I
in South Africa and I went to Robben
Island where Mandela and a lot of people
were imprisoned and it was crazy because
in the end Frank house in the last room
they really like it's really restrained
within the last year they have like
Mandela quotes he's like every man on
rather not and like had the N Frank
Diaries like holy [ __ ] so going there
it's like these disparate places did you
get to go into the actual attic or do
you just look into a seka - yeah and
it's I really like how they do it
because it's there's a couple
informational things but it's pretty
much just an empty apartment all the
furniture is out and everything and you
just kind of walk through the space and
that's part of why the lines are so long
because it's a very tiny little space
and only people a few people go in at a
time oh but yeah they kind of just let
the space speak for itself until you get
like to the final rooms when they talk
about it but how long are you how big is
the actual attic I can't it's not very
big I can't remember but like you I do
remember like sliding down hallways and
stuff like it's a really like tiny tiny
bookcase or something it was mine yes
right I want know what was Auschwitz
like is that I almost went there from my
final gig was in Amsterdam I almost went
to Auschwitz but it would've been all
like an 11-hour physical holiday yeah
but it's it's great it's really intense
and like I'm not like at the 9/11 museum
to where there's a terrible contrast
between like people who are you know
involved and where they are and like
kids running around like having no idea
where they are and you're like oh maybe
you shouldn't have kids like coming I
went into like the most graphic room in
the 9/11 museum there's a guy on a phone
going like yeah yeah I mean I love
museum yeah I'll be sure to put it like
this yeah context is everywhere
yeah people with such assets sometimes I
hear crazy no kind of awareness of their
surroundings yeah this is a quiet place
yeah you're not supposed to yell into
you're falling I'm sorry you said I
couldn't use it was this your place all
right sir they say no pictures - no I
and that must have been a difficult
thing to figure out I think we kind of
its kind of your view they leave it up
to you to bathe so most people do like
you know they have what do they have in
the 9/11 the fire truck that was crushed
right they have the a lot of the steel
right where the plane went in they had
the big antenna that was on top of the
building the museum is kind of tough
because it's all you know pictures and
everything but the space that they have
underneath where the I guess the
footprint of the building used to be is
pretty incredible just this giant place
and the wall that kept the river from
pouring in that they'd built in the 60s
oh yeah yeah it's green missus ciller
flush wall or something that's gonna the
slurry wall yeah well yeah and they have
a they actually have a piece of the
metal with a plane went in yeah right
yeah though you can see right where they
went it's yeah very intense well I'd
like to actually yeah look at that
building every day and I've never I've
never gone there you're not really a
sightseeing guy generally are you you
know something like that I would say I
mean of course I just I don't know why I
have that but I think it is sold out I
can just go and yeah you got to make an
appointment or said that I went I went
when it open but it's like yeah it felt
like a like go do it once thing if you
go like when you go places do you end up
trying to find what's there it was like
a in like yeah what's going on and South
Africa was like that too like every
weekend it's like alright we got to like
make sure you know this is the only if
the pilot doesn't get picked up we're
only gonna have one opportunity to see
so all the cable yeah I normally
normally do that did it get picked up we
find out July 14 oh use your shot what
was it was called Oasis it's a sci-fi
series and it's a the pilot from
everything on know that's teacher man
okay yeah that that will come out I
think all at once at the end of the
summer the fall okay so how'd you like
South Africa I liked it it was it was an
adventure and it just feels very very
far away it's like 17 hours from here
and yet with the time difference and
everything it just really feels like
you're off on you know really distant
land do you feel under threat at all cuz
I know that a lot of like the white
farmers have had problems they're like
it's a really weird history that place
has was scary at all it's so recent - I
mean yet a pretty high crime but you
know they they kept us safe but it is
very distressing to see like that those
divisions are still very much in force
and you know it only ended in the 90s so
like there is you know it's harder there
than it is in a lot of the places like I
want to go out and like
the city like me people and everything
because it's you know still pretty
pretty violent what do they say don't do
it yeah don't go certain places at night
and don't go alone and everything and
like I like God and maybe this is stupid
anywhere but it's like you know put in
my headphones and I kind of wander
around it's like you got to be a little
bit more aware there's your surrounding
yet now was it a segregated area learn
or no there's no segregated and I mean
it's not that anymore but that's one of
the dark legacies is that you can see
that there are very separated
neighborhoods and you know the wealthier
areas and then the townships and
everything that all those geographical
divisions are still there so our
director at Kevin Macdonald he's like
it's South Africa is interesting to see
whether this is the past becoming you
know a more unified future whether this
is a vision of the future for everywhere
of these kind of really intense
divisions you know they're sort of
figuring out and how to do that how are
we there I'm on oh okay so you got
Nelson Mandela's how far is that from
like downtown wherever you are that the
island is like an hour boat trips out
from the from the harbor and yeah that
island had been used as a prison since
the 1500s so there's all these different
you know eras of what they're using it
for and then you know the the most
recent being the apartheid government
putting it there but yeah it's
incredible they have the tour guides are
mostly former inmates they're former you
know prisoners that now you know do they
live in the houses that used to be the
prison guards houses and everything it's
really intense and guys like yeah like
this is where they used to beat me and
this is where I was you know in prison
for 20 years it's really intense you
imagine choosing to do that though like
not wanting to get as far away from as
possible I guess there's some poetic
justice and the back and a prison guards
house yeah you would first think like
you yeah you would never want to get
close to but also the trouble is a lot
of them just said openly it's like it's
tough to find jobs so this is a good way
to employ a lot of people who have you
know struggled since that era and you
know now they live in you know
relatively nice conditions on this
island cuz yeah that's with a lot of
places like oh it's a beautiful island
where all these horrible things happen
yeah there's a newsie it's cool you go
out and see places know like I tried to
and a lot of times I don't I saw
Alcatraz that was kind of fun have you
been in Alcatraz no I haven't yeah that
was really fun to her no one has ever
escaped from there
eight the no.1 slam I think people
escaped but we're lost like a couple
people that got out but never ever imma
go out in that in like the bay like that
water is so frightening lis choppy and
crazy like to think that anybody says to
when its laminated and it was the Anglin
brothers and Frank I forget his name
Frank something my memories were
starting to go boy but no can you look
up who escaped from off the transferee
Clint Eastwood played him oh yeah I
think you were kidding when you said
that yeah I mean the two brothers and
there was a fourth guy who panicked and
just stood there frozen in the movie his
name is Charlie but but forget what his
real name is that was a demon but it's
not his real name uh Frank Morris and
you're John and Clarence Anglin Wow got
out they were never found
so who they they don't know they they
had these little things from Popular
Mechanics that they blew up and they
were going to swim yet you want to
romanticize it and think that like same
thing with DB cooper that like somewhere
out there you know you did the way
nature works like we kind of know what
happened there's a reason why people
don't resurface yeah you never know they
did he get back then it was easier to
disappear in the 60s in 1970 because
everything wasn't digitally tracked
that's true yeah it's also really easy
to disappear at the bottom of the bay
but certainly I think it's probably
where they kept you guys I know but
they're not in jail anymore they never
found him no never found any any trace
of them anywhere but they said they do
is I've read they got picked up by a
boat but eventually actually they do
somebody would have I'm the guy yes
Emily came out somebody would have come
forward about me what's nuts that people
do it now like those guys in upstate New
York who escaped the maximum security
prison yeah you'd think we'd have the
technology that you can't like can't
happen and that woman who was like
blowing one of them oh they have that's
how they did yeah that lady who worked
there and she couldn't get enough
prisoner dick [ __ ] helped him get out
of jail and then but she she didn't help
them on the night of escape she bailed
out oh yeah I made it but it still came
after she was blowing all the prisoners
you know how mad you must have been if
you're [ __ ] having sex with her she
was like a three and then you [ __ ]
her and she just doesn't help you go to
jail doesn't show up with the car yeah
and that was my soliders wall three
years ago is that Travis Carroll
Tilly that's why her name is Fillie yeah
I think they're making a movie about
that oh yeah yeah I hope so I feel like
there's a renaissance right now going on
for you oh thanks you know I seems like
there's just a I don't know you're
you're popping up all over the place and
is this huge interest in in what you're
doing like now which is kind of Awesome
yeah got it what do you what do you do
you credit that to any thing specific
was there one project or something that
like like always sunny or whatever the
game idols yeah um yeah it's it's tough
to put to identify the moment and my you
know goal was always just to just work
on as many projects as possible and do
as many different characters as possible
I think Silicon Valley has probably been
the UH you know one of the biggest parts
I've gotten recently and it's a cool
show to be on it's been on for so many
years and to go on a show that I've been
a fan of for for so long like that's
been a cool thing but I did
Amazon's first streaming series alpha
house in 2013 and that was kind of when
I even though we shot that year I went
to school in New York City from 2006 to
like 2011 and then like 2013's when I
started like going back to LA and
started doing shows again getting back
into yeah why is um why is a TJ leaving
TJ Miller they say leaving talk about
yeah yeah yeah this is last season I
think you just so wanted to bring a
character to to an end and you know that
he and HBO mutually made the decision
but yeah it's a I know what happens to
his character this season but I can't
tell anyone at this point but uh yeah
I'm seeing him tonight actually the
premiere for his uh his comedy special
which is also for HBO oh yeah
funny I don't know if I send it to him I
saw a really cool poster I was in Times
Square and there was a giant TJ Manila
yeah I might've tweeted or something
that's really cool it's got two words
the name of it
what you want the name of it is
meticulously ridiculous yeah so he's a
funny dude yeah yeah eight years of
pushing that comedy special hard whoever
yeah every different kind of alley
before before it starts realizing
Marshall for the comedy special yeah
pushing they pushed uh who's gonna get
to do the show black comic oh my god
Jojo I comical they put his special
things really funny and I was in LA and
he had like the side of a building
like see I think it's a Netflix they're
pushing the specials that they get very
how it's actually play a really good
time to do an HBO special yeah because
they're going to promote you more than
they probably right five years ago right
that's true but Netflix always a
surprise just when I turn on the the app
if I go like this three Dave Chappelle
specials of it right once a week they're
releasing a special yeah it's amazing
how [ __ ] how many people are doing
but sometimes you just won't see it and
it'll be like oh my god look this guy
like Jim Norton's got a new special yeah
that's a month old
we're like the good part is that nobody
it just sits there
yeah a people could just look you up and
go and get it that's kind of a great
part the bad part is you're competing
with Chappelle and Louis right did you
leave acting to go to college yeah I
part of the reason I chose NYU is that
they were very accommodating for me
leaving to do things so I did one play
on Broadway
and one movie when I was in college but
ultimately it was like I realized in
school for like 20 years if I kept
working and uh delaying classes and
everything so I finished up in 2011 and
then it was yeah coming back to it to
doing regular things but ya know what
did you know I was gonna like what makes
you want to go to school because like as
somebody who went to school just K
through 12 and then college like no part
of me wanted to go to college I didn't
want to stay in college like but it
wasn't like I had options yeah anything
else oh no I feel like I might anything
else going on I would have not done that
I suppose so and like as a business
decision maybe it wasn't the the most
effective thing to do but just
personally I knew I wanted to go and it
was a time to really sort of the last
chance to figure out like do I really
want to do this like what should I only
be doing with my life and it was pretty
clear once I got there that I did want
to be doing it in and just the
experience of I went to theater school
so learning you know techniques for
stage and everything I think was really
helpful and continues to be helpful on
stuff that I'm doing now but even if I
hadn't wanted to my mom as a sixth grade
teacher both my parents were very perot
education so from a very young age it
was like I was going to
College I was going to finish everything
and was glad to do that because you can
always go back and do it but there's
just something about being like 18 and
being in New York City and you know
media those people and it was you know
making really good friends that now it's
fun because they are popping up you know
my friend Sarah Sutherland is on V
playing Selena's daughters oh that's
awesome another a person from from my
class Olivia Sandoval's on Fargo this
season so it's alright yeah beyond yeah
like Silicon Valley beef yeah like three
of the best shows to be on it seems like
you know it's funny people with child
actors who become successful adult
actors a lot of them have had a break
for college
well yourself you're doing well I mean
Brooke Shields Jodie Foster Yale yeah
yeah I mean sometimes that like break
and all the sudden you come back in a
couple of years it's not a long layoff
but just a couple of years and feeling
okay this is a new person though yeah
it's nice to have a foundation outside
of the industry and that's the time when
you really establish that I think is
having you know friends from outside the
industry and and you know yeah just a
life outside of doing shows and to get
you I mean that's a smart that I never
even occurred to me that thing that you
said just a minute ago which is you get
a second to get your head together to
figure out if you actually want to do
this because when you're a kid it's like
it's cool to be on a commercial then yes
I'll do this movie and then you're on
this cycle that you at some point have
to ask like that I choose this like
you're right is this what I want and if
you ultimately decide you don't want to
do it like having no other money I don't
that's what yeah so yeah how much did
you get laid in college because I'm sure
you still like being to iconic films and
more than that but I mean two iconic
films very recognizable you must have
been [ __ ] dump it all over the place
yeah I don't think those were helpful
cuz like being a kid in those movies I
hope no was watching back ok yeah what
about that kid for the ghost and robot
yeah but uh no I'll just say being in
New York at 18 is a good time being in
theater school great group of people
yeah why but I eat it I'm very kid you
were nominated right and you know even
if you're even if you were a kid then
you can still go to theater school and
be like well I mean yeah as an Oscar
nominated performer what I would do here
and it's got a help yeah yeah I mean
it's uh
what was nice is a lot of people at at
the program and while you were more
experienced than me and in a lot of ways
you know for staged everything they were
one of my friends got hired right out of
college to start to sell a so you had
this very broad you know diversity and
people the skill sets that was cool to
me around yeah quickly you and your
nominees who won Michael came my thing
about it was before
for Cider House Rules and we we work
together like a year after that on
secondhand lions too which was pretty
cool so yeah when you're a kid like how
does how's a kid react to being
nominated for an Oscar like did you want
to win this the way a kid wants to win
anything or did you not even really get
it's the whole thing it's like a whole
season of press and promoting it and
like other awards show like it's the
last award show of the season so by then
you've done like the Golden Gloves and
SAG Awards and all these other things so
I trying to remember my mindset back
then I don't think I like really wanted
to win like eating a cry when you open
up area 11 and yeah I mean I had just
met with Steven Spielberg for the first
time before the Oscars when he was
getting ready to do AI and he was like
the I'll tell you the best part about
this whole thing he's like at the Oscars
pay attention during the commercial
breaks because you'll see all these big
stars that you know running around like
fans to meet people that they're fans of
and and that was like the coolest part
about it it's like yeah you just you
know have this incredible assortment of
people I mean that year the the category
I was in was Tom Cruise Michael Caine
Michael Clarke Duncan and choose law oh
my god and it was just yeah cool cuz
there's a set of five people going to
all these to the luncheon and everything
so you got all of them yeah yeah and at
one point during during the Oscars Jude
ran over to me the first time I met him
he was like it's a secret but apparently
playing robots in this new movie and I'm
like oh yeah like kind of a cool moment
right you enjoyed the experience yeah
yeah it was terrific but how do your
parents protect you from the whole thing
because the industry can be if you don't
enjoy it it can be a pretty toxic yeah
well just by being there I mean my dad
was usually the one with me and he was a
big part of me learning how to act as he
he studied theater in college he ran
a theater on Santa Monica Boulevard in
the 80s so a lot of my training came
from from his techniques and everything
but yeah there just were always on set
and now it's kind of crazy to me because
it seems like a lot of work doing a show
and when I was a kid you also have to do
it by California well three hours of
school every day with a tutor so there
was that on top of shooting everything
so school was a big stabilizing thing
because I went to a regular elementary
school high school and you know finally
finished up in college so having that
foundation having parents around you
know wasn't going to the the weird
parties or anything
it seemed a sad